Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and during the
Marvel special tonight we got our first look
at some concept art for Avengers 2 that gives
us an idea for what Quicksilver and Scarlet
Witch will look like and we saw some Iron
Man Hulkbuster armor.
Which kind of informs what some of the plot
is going to be.
The special itself was really fun and was
just a deep dive behind the scenes into the
creative process of Marvel Studios from a
business and a creative perspective.
So I’m going to focus mostly on the Avengers
2 parts and Phase 3 but I’ll mention some
of the other fun facts.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I do Marvel movie videos every tuesday.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
feel free to suggest future videos for me
to do.
So Let’s start with the important stuff.
The children of he must not be named, because
of copyright.
They haven’t started principal photography
on their scenes yet, most of the footage we’ve
seen from Johannesburg was all second unit
stuff.
So all of this was concept art.
But it is what they’ll actually look like.
It’s just the plainclothes millennial version
of the characters.
Maybe during the course of the film they’ll
get official costumes like Captain America
got his new costume during the first Avengers.
I won’t talk about it here, but I there
is a scene with these two characters you can
see pretty soon in the theater.
If you want spoilers for that just watch my
Avengers 2 video I posted last week.
There’s a link to that at the end of this
video.
Now let’s talk about that Hulkbuster Armor.
It’s a slightly modified and colored version
of the armor we saw in Iron Man 3.
Meaning He’s rebuilt some of his armory,
and the Hulk is going to be a huge green problem
in Avengers 2.
In the comics there’s a really notable story
called World War Hulk.
It takes place after the Planet Hulk storyline.
Hulk just comes back to earth and beats the
crap out of every single superhero that he
can see.
A lot of people, myself included thought that
they would do something like this eventually,
but this is a lot sooner than expected.
And it’s going to be a lot of fun.
In the first film he didn’t really collide
with the team too much.
It seems like in the sequel, Mark Ruffalo
be smashing a lot more stuff.
Side note too, the Red Hulk was also a big
part of the Age of Ultron comic book story.
That story won’t be what this film is, but
it’s a nice coincidence.
Plus I think everyone wants a Mark Ruffalo
standalone Hulk film at some point.
And there wasn’t any James Spader Ultron
concept art, but here’s some interesting
info on the movie’s story.
The larger story.
It’s mostly going to be inspired by the
Mighty Avengers Ultron Initiative, that’s
where Ultron takes over the Armor of Tony
Stark.
It came after the Civil War storyline.
You can read the comics if you want to learn
more.
Now, let’s talk phase 3 real quick before
we do some fun Avengers facts.
Feige repeated some earlier comments about
the changing Avengers roster, mostly referring
to Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch.
But then they also played the old Ant-Man
test footage.
In my Ant-Man preview video earlier today
I predicted that Ant-Man would eventually
become an Avengers during the third movie.
It’s not rocket science though, Scott Lang
became an Avenger in the comics.
That really makes me wonder who they’re
going to cycle out of the Avengers.
Robert Downey Jr’s last movie is Avengers
3, after that unless he takes a major pay
cut, they’ll be forced to cut him out or
re-cast the part.
It’s already pretty obvious that they’re
building towards Infinity Guantlet, but it’s
a little early to be doing Avengers 3 videos.
Feel free to ask me more questions about how
all that ties together.
Largely SHIELD and The Guardians of the Galaxy
will be the connective tissue between the
cosmic elements of the films and the earth
based films.
So eventually Agent Coulson and Star Lord
will be sharing some screen time.
Here’s a couple Marvel and Avengers behind
the scenes facts from the special that I thought
were pretty cool.
Starting things off, when they first got stared
with Iron Man.
Almost every writer in Hollywood they offered
it to turned it down.
The only reason they were able to obtain financing
for the first couple of films was by bundling
them together in what would eventually be
known as the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
So it wasn’t just a creative decision.
They did it because financially, that’s
the only way the bank would buy into it.
During the first Iron Man, after Gwyneth Paltrow
signed on to the project and came in to meet
with Favreau and RDJ for the first time, they
all ended up crying because they were so happy.
Samuel L Jackson won the role of Nick Fury
in that same Iron Man film because his agent
cold called Kevin Fiege and they loved the
idea.
The Tesseract became the first big macguffin.
The thing that drove the plot forward with
very little if no explanation.
In phase 2 it’s the infinity gems and in
phase 3 it will be the infinity gauntlet.
George RR Martin even got a cameo in the special.
Turns out the Avengers were what made him
fall in love with comics as a child.
He did a podcast with Nerdist talking about
going to the first ever comic book convention
in the world.
I’ll post a link to that in the description.
So we saw a ton of stuff.
Let me know of that new stuff, the Avengers
and Guardians of the galaxy footage.
What you’re most excited to see.
Guardians is really only a couple months away.
Eventually Marvel could get to the point too
where it releases four films a year.
There’s just so much material and their
creative process has become so efficient.
Let me know which films you want to see after
phase 3 is over.
I know, I know.
Deadpool.
We’re all thinkin’ the same thing.
Right now click here for my Ant Man preview
and click here for my Avengers 2 preview.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight!